hello well welcome everyone to this nice
very nice introduction and thank you
Quincy it's oh boy
I think one day if I need someone to if
I need someone to sell myself I will
definitely hire Quincy so let me know if
everything is right if you can hear me
my name is Lauren pop I'm a developer
from Romania
I've been coding for seven years and in
November I started a YouTube channel you
can subscribe there if you want to
follow me we have almost daily live
streams and different tutorials and also
if you want feel free to follow me on
Twitter we're posting almost daily and
yeah let's start working on this new
crazy challenge Quincy has been has been
asking me to start this because well
yeah it's an interesting challenge and
we're going to do it on the free code
camp website and we're going to do it
with JavaScript which is pretty nice
yeah hello Eduardo feel free feel free
to join the chat this will be this won't
be that kind of animal tutorial where
I'm teaching you and I know it's all
formal it's just us hanging out sort of
and solving coding challenges with
JavaScript
this is whoops this is what I'm doing on
my channel also so I haven't prepared
for these challenges because I wanted
you to to see the progress so I wanted
you to see that it's it's okay to fail
it's okay to Google sometimes things
it's okay to not have the perfect
solution and yeah it's all part of
developer
journey keep in mind that I've been
programming for seven years I've been
working as a freelancer I had a job than
freelancer again and another job and
then I turned into content creator this
is what I really like to do so yeah
thank you freakin camp for giving me
this huge opportunity
I usually stream for 4050 people there
are thousands and so people now watching
which is crazy I was pretty nervous but
now I find ya so say hi in the chat if
you're watching if you can also it's
don't tell anyone but my opinion you
should support a freaking cab Channel
it's they're doing an amazing thing so
feel free to become a member and then
you will be able to join the chat if you
have questions at any time feel free to
ask them also I might need your help
sometimes so feel free to help me and
yeah hello TM sunny Eric hi all of you
okay so yeah let's see what's the take a
jar how are you today so this is the
project Euler set of problems coding
challenges I will be this will be the
first series and then I will be doing I
think weekly live streams in which we're
going over these problems there are
hundreds of problems but this challenge
is the first 100 now I'm not sure if we
can go over all of them like that fast
because they're getting harder and
harder but well we're going to try all
right so yeah project Euler is the
cities of challenging mathematical and
computer programming problems meant to
delve delve into and familiarize oh by
the way if my English is I think she's
off that's because of nothing in native
English speakers so yeah any time you
don't understand what I'm rambling
around
feel free to stop me and yeah wait what
as I said I usually am on my channel
we're all here as a family we're
learning together we're having fun I
don't have my orange lemonade now you
really have an origin mone don't we yeah
we had worth having fun okay
so I was thinking that in this stream we
should do the first four or five
problems to see how it goes as I said I
haven't really look into it just that
just the titles but we should be fine
hopefully hello Travis how it's going
also so yeah the first problem
multiplies of three and five if we list
all the natural numbers below 10 that
are multiplies of three or five we get
three five six and nine all right
the sum of this multiplies is 23 okay so
we need to add up the sum of the
multiplies of three or five
all right find the sum of all the
multiples of three or five below the
provided parental value number okay so
apparently we have a function which gets
in a number and we need to return the
sum of the multiplies all right so let's
see first we should probably loop over
all the numbers from 1 up to well the
number provided and we should check if
that number so all the numbers in the
loop if there are multiplies of 3 or 5
so if they their modulus I guess the
division by 3 doesn't have any reminders
hopefully I said that right right
okay so hey Adam yeah thank you
good so let's see we want to create our
loop let me know if the font size is big
enough if you can see the code I don't
know if my face is in the way or I
should probably remove these social
buttons or whatever they are and yeah if
anything is not okay just let me know
and we can fix it all right so we're
going to do a for loop starting with one
well I guess yeah we should start with
one because we could have a number less
than three right so we should start with
one and then we want to go up to the
number right
so I less equals than the number I plus
plus okay and so first I'm going to do
like a brute force thing so not very
optimized and then we can try to improve
it if if we find find a better way to do
it
hello Marco so yeah thank you by the way
thank you to all the poppers the poppers
are those who been following me yeah the
poppers family thank you all of you for
being part of this
you've been very supportive I was very
nervous at the beginning and yet highly
appreciate you being here also Marco
seems that he became a member to be in
the chat so yeah very nice of you all
right so we're looping over all these
numbers now we need to see if they are
multiplies of multiplies of three or
five I guess I don't need this anymore
all right so let's check here if I right
so if I modulus three is zero or what
and that's yeah you'll hear a lot of
oops you're here a lot of goody-goodies
your Hill a lot of things I just hope
you enjoy it and the most important
thing I really hope that you're learning
something and yeah what we should be
looking for is to become every day to
become just you know if we can become
one percent better than we were
yesterday that's already a huge so yeah
good so one one zero is five equals zero
I always mix up it is the modulus
operator or yeah someone correct me if
I'm wrong I might be wrong multiple
times oh that's right okay so if that's
the case then we want to add this I to a
sub right so let's create the sum with
let not beat Const let's um first will
be equal to zero
and here we can say some classical's i
right and so they will add up let's make
some space here to have a pretty code
and at the end we should return some
right hmm
if my logic is correct hopefully it is
this should be good so let's see all
right something is off
what did I do wrong so if it's three or
five then we should add AI K up mm that
should be hmm does anyone notice and
think where it could be the issue
all right let's let's console that clock
and see what we get so for a thousand we
should get to top two hundred thirty two
thousand one hundred sixty-eight and we
get oh okay I think I know where the
problem is so you can see the difference
between this and the value we should get
it's like 1000 and 1000 is the number
we're looking so yeah it says here below
the provided very parametric value so
that's the issue we went up to including
the number so we just need to remove
here the equals and now you can see that
we are getting the correct answer and
let's run this and look at that pretty
nice we solve the first one awesome all
right let's think yeah I less the number
Thank You Kaja I also keep in mind that
there might be a delay from the time
you're saying this well do the time
you're commenting in the chat and I'm
saying that so yeah keep that in mind
all right
could we improve this or should we think
about improving something like this I
always try to think maybe we could have
some kind of ray method or something
fancy but yeah it doesn't seem like you
know we should even think about
something it's pretty clear we have a
sum which is zero then we'll loop over
all the numbers and if they are
multiplies of three or five then we are
the sum so I guess this should be a
pretty good solution if you have an idea
of how can we prove this maybe I don't
see it or who knows
let me know but for now let's submit
this angle to the next challenge
all right good the second one even
Fibonacci numbers now let's see what
this requires each new term in a
Fibonacci sequence is generated by
adding the previous two terms by
starting with one and two so yeah we
have one and two the next one will be
one plus two for those who don't know
about the Fibonacci sequence then we
have two plus three equals five then we
have three plus five equals 8 and then
we have so so on and so forth
all right by considering the terms in
the Fibonacci sequence whose values do
not exceed an so again we don't need to
go over and find the sum of the even
value terms alright so let's take some
notes we need to not exceed and what I'm
writing here okay so up to n then we
need even numbers all right and we need
the numbers will be in a Fibonacci
sequence right okay look at this
motivating message you can do it alright
we can do
so I guess we should start by having the
Fibonacci numbers the first two
Fibonacci numbers right okay so the
Fibonacci values should not exceed all
right so let's do the following let a be
the first one or I guess we could call
it a be the first B one and let be me
too okay so these are the first two
Fibonacci numbers and now we want to go
to keep adding these and changing the
these variables this is why I used to
add until we are up to the app so again
now because we don't know exactly
last time we use the for loop because we
knew exactly how many steps we have but
this time we don't know exactly the
number of steps so we're going to use a
while loop so then we're going to use
while and we need a condition here which
will be the condition so in the next
loop B will equal well a will equal B so
a will be two and B will equal a plus B
right so it will be the next number so
we need to check while B less than and
right so this is our not exceeding it
okay and also need to keep in mind that
we need the even numbers all right and
we need a sound so let's create that
variable sum will be let's think we want
the sum to be zero or we want the sum to
be a plus B by default I guess will be a
plus B
oh but no because a will be an odd
number so we only want the even number
so that's be right we should we have be
less than and Escada
no because we want to go up to and
knotek's oh yeah see yeah you're right
so it not exceeding means that it
doesn't go over so it could be up to and
including very good thanks
yeah so nothing's not exceeded but
included okay good good catch
see ya we might sometimes just mess it
up but it's fine and this is why I like
the live streams well on one hand I just
just I know get the fool of myself but
on the other hand I have helped my
helpers here which will make sure that
whenever I fail it will still around
okay yeah and we'd also figure out when
the code fails so probably this is a bit
overthinking on my side just to buy the
know lay out the building structures I
guess the oh okay so here we want to get
the new values so the new Fibonacci
number which has said that a will be B
and B will be a plus B but here is an
issue because now we modified a here so
we need a temporary value in which we're
going to store a then we're going to
change a to be B so it will be the next
element in the Fibonacci sequence and
then here instead of storing into a
we're going to do temporary plus B all
right and
now if B is even so meaning that the
division back to the reminder should be
zero right so if it's even we want to
add it to the Sun so sound plus equals B
now if my logic is correct and I didn't
screw it up at the end we should [ __ ]
some and let's run to see look at that
so this time we did it correctly yeah
let me know if you understood this let
me know if you have any questions I'm
going to wait after I finish one one
challenge just to make sure that
everything is you understood everything
yeah so apparently all the tests here
running correctly for ten it should be a
number sixty one thousand one hundred
thousands of these numbers go like so
big which is pretty pretty interesting
okay
I don't see any questions in the chat so
I guess we can go to the next one now
mmm well actually let me think could we
improve this anyway
I don't have an adn now I'm thinking
about using recursion to find out the
Fibonacci numbers but yeah that's
probably not for this challenge
so yeah let's move on to the next one
all right largest prefect or prime
factor okay so the prime factor of
13,000 195 are five seven thirteen and
twenty nine what is the largest prime
factor of the given number okay
so let's see that's right again what we
need to do so mm-hmm we need the prime
factor so not only the factor is the
prime on so we need to check and we need
to have a function is prime okay so well
let's see this will check if a number is
prime okay all right then we would
probably loop again over the entire
numbers as we did in the first challenge
so from 1 up to the number but I knew
that there is a trick so we don't
actually have to go up to the number
because I think there was either going
up up to the half of the number or the
square root of the number so I never
really really got this exactly so we're
going to test it because you can see
here we have a huge huge huge number and
well doing the loop over let's see
thousand millions billions that's well
that's huge
also being the prime weekend we need to
check all the number so we need to check
if is divisible by only one and itself
so it doesn't have any divisors I guess
yeah
so for loop up to
to half let's go up to half of the
number because so if you're thinking
about twenty right so then which is half
of it
it is a divisor right but eleven it's
not anymore and also twelve and thirteen
all the numbers from half up but also
ten it's not a prime because yeah it has
it divisible by 2 and 5 hmm
okay let's loop so we need often just
the largest so we're going to keep track
of the largest so that largest first
will be and should start with one and
now we're going to let me remove this so
for left I equals I think we can start
with two or should one is definitely not
the biggest but oh well let's start with
1 I less than or equal to half of the
number number divided by 1/2 divided by
2 and I plus plus okay now we need to
check if is prime so the i if is prime
and well actually we can do i number
modulus equals zero and it's a prime
right
so prime factors okie-dokie and I did
this we're going to create another
function just to make it more readable
so is Prime and we're going to give it a
number and here let's see we want to
start from two so let I equals 2 because
1 is divisible so being a prime means
it's only divisible by 1 and itself
so we want to loop over all the other
numbers or so from 2 up to the number
and if we find the divisor then it's
another prime okay I guess this also
could go up to 1/2 hmm let's do the
brute force and then if it fails we can
optimize it so let I equal to I less
than the number I plus plus
okay
and now if number divisible by zero then
we can already return false right so we
get up the function and we turn false
otherwise we can return true and this is
a prime number so let me put this here
nice little bit okay so
[Laughter]
Quincy again speaking highly of me but I
don't deserve it okay so we're looking
over the numbers and now if this is the
case so if it's divisible and if it's a
prime then we want to store it in the
largest so largest should be I right
because that's the little loop okay and
here we can return the largest
all right this is my logic let's see if
it's a good one okay so something's
wrong
let's do some yeah look at that test
timed out so this might be a problem for
us
okay because it's a huge number I said
that we'll do four or five but maybe
we'll get stuck at three alright first
let's let's cancel that lot to see what
we get and whites and not working okay
so for this we get 29 that's good for
two we get two one
okay that's because we go up to half and
apparently doesn't good so
let's see what happens for three I guess
it's the same thing and we get only one
four five
yes apparently that's not okay let's go
up to the number prime factors
yeah feel free to correct me if you see
the mistake there might be a couple all
right so this should work for few but
Danakil
Thank You Quincy yeah also feel free to
support the freaking camp channel by
donating if you want super chat it will
help the organization
alright now yeah this is what I was
afraid of we're passing these these
tests but the big one is pretty big I'm
happy to see that you enjoyed it Adam
yeah this is what I did with the free
code camp curriculum and also I'm going
to do it again with the Piton series
after everything's working and all
always good
so Andrews saying that in is prime only
need to check if number is divisible by
two three five and seven all other
numbers are divisible by one of these
ends if not a prime value
yeah but it could be a for example 13 is
a prime
so I'm not sure if that will work
yes sir now it's failing because of its
test timeout so we need to reduce the
number of loops we have
which will be pretty interesting
and yeah so cassia is saying so if I
mispronounce your name sorry it's saying
that instead of for lo pruning running
from one equal from I equals to one can
we run i cost a number divided by two
till i is bigger than one so you're
saying which should look backwards yeah
that would be an idea and then we save
half of the half of the loops
yeah and I'm glad I did okay but then
well we're going to have the same issue
where we won't have to entry if we do
equals the half of the number right and
we can also not change the largest so
let let's comment this out we need to do
something
slowly figure it out
they're probably must be some kind of
fancy thing to delete but let's try this
so let by equals number divided by two I
bigger than I guess one we can go there
I I - - so we go the other way around
and I guess we can check the same thing
now the issue here will be for example
for - we won't have to write and also I
let's make it let's floor this number so
we have a fixed number so fluorine if
the number is not a prime it is bound to
have a factor factor less then its
square root according to the common
mathematical theorem yeah so this is
Matt Matt Matt ish yes I knew something
about the square root so you say that
here we should go up to the square root
of number Matt square root right so this
should save some loops also if you check
divisibility by two before the loop you
can start with I equals three and
increment by 2 instead of incremented by
1
that's another good good suggestion
because we know that 4 is not a prime
right so what you're saying here is that
we can start with 3 we can increment by
2 so it will be 3 5 7 9 and here if the
number is divisible by 2 then we can
return false right so this is 4 for the
two case alright for two kids
[Laughter]
and yeah for case we're divisible by two
yeah I wanted to the comment nevermind
alright so this will save a lot of loops
to check the prime let's see how this
works for a number now
yes so it still should return to
still timed out why did you have to do
so big of a number alright so let's
think well this is divisible by two but
if it's two we want to return true right
it might be two the number itself might
be two so then it we should allow it so
we need to check if is divisible by 2
and the number is different than two
then we should return false right and
now it should work for for this test
case but we still have a lot of loops
IFS
[Music]
let's see what we could improve I could
try this now but yeah my only issue with
this is that the largest yeah you can
see that it's not working I guess we
could do a seal but still we don't yet
we don't get to mm-hm all right so this
doesn't work now we need to work on this
one okay now for the prime factors here
also we shouldn't go up the number
think
go to the square root right
and we can also do what we did here
skipping to at the time so one three
like that
two two two two
well let's try
[Laughter]
okay now we get to a one
so we have this case in there's where
the largest prime factor it's the number
itself
whoa but look at this so we kind of
passed the test the big one which is
pretty great
that means that we're not timed out
anymore which is pretty pretty great now
the only thing we need to figure out is
what are we doing when the large prime
factor is the number itself
two two two two two
let's think so
[Music]
but wise oh well I guess I think I know
so if the number itself is a prime then
that's the largest right so here we can
just check if is prime so if the number
is prime then we can just return the
number right because it's itself and
otherwise we need to do all this
mumbo-jumbo fingerprint
[Laughter]
all right look at that we have one
percent done of and this project Euler
pretty nice so yeah see how we started
with a brute-force and we slowly slowly
adjusted the code to be faster and
better and yeah okay yeah also marco is
having good point
someone also suggested this if we start
from the back and yeah that will speed
it up even even faster because yet the
reason I didn't do from the back it's
that we had this case scenario when we
needed to return the number so I guess
this is in the case where the number
itself is a prime so then in order to
simplify this well to speed this up even
more we could do that we could start by
setting I to be square root of the
number we could we could go down to 1
and we could do I minus 2 so this way
whenever well I guess we could even
not store the largest and just return
now so if we find something like this
return i right
because we're fighting so the first one
that's divisible by the number the is
divisible by the number and if it's
prime then it's the bigger bigger
biggest prime right
okay I think this speeds it up even more
let's see okay so something's not good
so square root we go up to one oh I see
where we might so we might go we might
skip the square root here might be
something like an even number right so
it might be something like 30 and then
we're going to 28:26 24 so we're
dropping like with two and they're all
even number so they're not primes right
then we need to see if this is even so I
guess I could just tour
so this is we'll already solve the
problem and it works but sometimes it's
good to stretch it a little bit more to
make it better if you Canon well if you
have the time I yeah I have the time so
let's stretches stretch this even more
so we want to store the square root
right and we want to see if it's an even
number and we'll start with that
hello Edmundo and Lawrence thank you on
behalf of free code camp not sure Quincy
if I can do that to it thank you on
behalf of a code camp for supporting
their neuron that organ is organization
all right so we start with this and if
the square root is an even number then I
guess let's add one to it so square root
plus equals one right and now we can
start with the
the square root here and hopefully this
will fix the bug we had and also speed
this up even even faster okay so no hmm
wasn't this the problem let's see what
we get so if we do undefined okay so
probably getting here it's not a number
are we skipping it
hmm let's cancel the flog all the ice to
see okay so yeah look at that
that's not good we have decimals so
let's floor this all right
and now do we get look at that we get 29
so yeah should this work now us perfect
I don't have time now but if you do have
time use this solution and try to see
what's the difference in the speed with
the solution we had earlier but they say
this is much much faster yeah although
the curve is not the prettiest but oh
okay let me know if you have any
questions for this one don't be shy in
the chat if you're in the chat say hi
say say why say whatever you want
it's a open communication it's not don't
let me feel yeah all right so I guess we
can submit this and go to the fourth one
right ask me later please okay let's see
palindrome this is nice so the largest
palindrome product a palindromic number
reads the same boat both ways so for
example 1 1 2 2 1 1 is the palindrome
because you can redo the same backwards
and forwards or 1 0 0 1 or we have here
9 0 0 9 so it's the same it's the same
thing select the chat
[Music]
okay
not sure conceived Markham meant about
project Euler to the back or just just
the the challenge itself
all right the largest palindrome made
from the product of two digit number is
nine thousand and nine so 91 times 99
find the largest palindrome made from
the product of two and digit numbers
okay
you
hmm this is now quite interesting so yet
there aren't a lot of taste test cases
first we need to construct this number
so these three digit numbers two digit
numbers and we can start the same way we
did the previous challenge so with the
biggest number and then slowly decrease
but the there's a catch here
so what's the largest palindrome made
from the product because well I'm
thinking about having two loops right
starting with 99 and 99 and then we do
99 times 99 or 99 times 9 8 and so on
and so forth but then if we only drop in
one loop we might get to a palindrome
but then might not be the largest
let's see
so $4.99 we could 99 times 99 then drop
to see in this case the correct answer
is 99 times 91 so we could continue to
drop one number right but something like
this 97 and then we eventually get to 99
times 91 which in this case works but we
might get down to 99 times I don't know
for the three digits we might get down
to 99 999 times I don't know 101 for the
three digits
let me put three digits here and this
could be a palindrome but it could not
be the biggest
the largest okay also we need a function
to determine is palindrome this is
another thing we have to do and yeah I
was thinking also to drop them by one
but then the toast also not it's not the
best or we could just do the brute force
Cal see all the palindromes and then
return the largest yeah I think that
should we start okay so let's have an
array palindromes like this and now
we're going to have two loops so
starting with I equals so the N we're
getting is the digit and in order to
have so if we get to the big we want to
start from 99 so let's see two two two
two two
[Music]
it could do something like so the
the number could be array array of n
this will create an array of length n
fill it up with nines and then join it
so yeah let me show you what this black
magic is so we're creating an array of
length N and this array will be empty
and then we're filling it up with the
number nut so let me console like all
the steps here so you can see so array
of n then console dot log array of n
fill with nine see we have an empty
array and we have an array of 999 and
then well we can cancel out this number
which is array field join you can see
here we have 999 but what this doesn't
show is that this is a string so well we
could say type off so you can see it's a
string but we need a number so in order
to convert to number we could use
percent like this or what I usually do
it's a at the plaza front where's the
buff yeah all right okay
now we have a number and this is the
biggest number so I guess I could say
biggest oh no just leave it number all
right now let's go back to our loop
well not sure I did if there we need the
for-loop so let I will be number I
greater than equals to 1 and I - - then
for let J equals number so we want two
loops because we want to do the
multiplication there J greater than
equals to 1 J minus - ok and now if I
times J is a palindrome so is palindrome
then we want to push it to the
palindromes array and we're pushing to
the array and then at the end we're
going to get the biggest number
palindromes that push
well let's store this Const
multiplication I times J and here we can
do multiplication or and here if it's a
palindrome we can do that alright let's
return the palindromes here just to have
something returned and let's create the
is palindrome function so function is
palindrome and we get here a number how
do we check if this number is a
palindrome okay so I can see here
there's an infinite loop
nickels ki- - I don't see why
hmm that's interesting
okay yeah that's what I want to do Mike
did it already so we have a number and
we need to check well we need to reverse
it and check with itself right and if
they are equal then that's vulnera so I
want to return here the value of number
two string and show you why we needed
two string equals two
number two string again so we're
converting it to string because we can
do now
split so we can get all the characters
of the string and convert them into an
array we can reverse this array reverse
oops
can type and then we can join it back to
a string so now this is the reverse
string of the number and this is the
number all right let's see so two string
is played in an array we reverse the
array and then we join back to a string
but it still says that might be an
infinite loop
why
you
you
[Music]
can anyone see
ever function
yeah it's fact we want to use a arrow
functions now but well guess we can't we
could so why is this well now we have
all the palindromes right but well I
guess I need to forget to console that
vlog this so here we should get a bunch
of palindromes look at that
so these are all the palindromes which
are quite a lot and we need to get the
maximum from this we can do that easily
by saying Mad Max and with the structure
the array so it will go inside the
method max function
and it should work now yeah I still
don't know why it said that we have an
infinite loop
okay what will happen if we say four
here yeah so it might run for a while
this is why probably
here the time test test stand out
[Music]
you
and it's interesting so maybe if number
is negative then there is an infinite
loop because it will never be positive
again well the number can be negative
here we have 2 & 3 so from the test
cases we can't really have a negative
number and also if it's negative then
this condition will be false right and
it will not loop
yeah so it shouldn't if the number is
less than one
then this condition will be false so it
will run well it will get up to the loop
all right yeah so this works
although yeah I kind of don't understand
why they say it's anything look oh wow I
guess it works let's see if we could
improve this so one way
now we're looping over all the numbers
so if we have 99 we're having 99 times
99 loops which is a lot and well in this
case we only should look like eight
times nine times to get to this value
how can we
how can we get to number to the to the
big largest number faster so we don't
have to loop over because it is not the
best way now we're just getting all the
Palin terms let's see
last night
and don't quite have an idea now
[Music]
there is something should be something
so we can stop sooner
you
maybe saved a number yeah yeah that will
be actually good we save but it's it
improves it bad because instead of
having an array of I don't know thousand
numbers or and which is not that big
we just have one number but yeah that's
that makes sense so console are just I
guess this needs to be minus infinity so
the lowest number possible if it's
palindrome and and
and the multiplication is bigger than
the largest then here we can set the
largest to be the multiplication right
so now we don't do this we just say
largest and we need to convert this to
let because we can't reassign constant
okay this should still work and we saved
a bit of time here that's right I'm just
looking here so I don't want this kind
of
mm-hmm
you
okay yeah I guess we should move on and
if you yeah by the way I didn't say this
in the beginning I should have these
challenges you should try to do them on
your own and then well these life stone
will be uploaded and probably this
section of project Euler will be
uploaded separately so you can watch it
then right
the loop doesn't need to continue if
much smaller than largest perhaps yeah
it might student but so for example in
this case we get 291 times 99 right so
we only have like 10 loops but we could
get so we might have a case where we
have like 98 times something being the
biggest so then because of this number
going lower than jumping back up 99
multiplied by this number being wants
being a smaller number then the product
of them will be bigger so yeah that's
also not that's also not the perfect
solution
all right yeah I guess huh let's leave
it like this for now I kind of have
something in my mind somewhere I think I
saw this but they for some reason can't
remember now so if you find this
dissolution please let me know well the
faster solution and I'll be glad to take
a look and I'm curious
I make search for it after this dream
all right and let's see
okay
let's wrap it up now we did four let's
go back so we did four challenges and
we're going to I'm not sure yet on which
days I'm going to be live on free code
camp we still not to still have to
figure that out but I'm going to be live
every week and we're going to continue
this now for those of you who are
watching and I highly recommend you
taking part of this challenge it's
pretty fun I recommend that you'll take
a look at these problems and try to
solve them on your own and when I'm
doing live during the live and well
don't spoil the answer to me but then
you can see how I'm solving it and well
it it will be much much useful for you
than just seeing me solve this right so
yeah I guess I guess that's it I hope
you liked it let me know in the chat if
you did and if you won meat is still to
continue to do this
thank you for Africa camp for letting me
do this on their channel it's a no it's
more than I ever expected I'm doing very
grateful for that and yeah let's help
developers get better programming find
it well my job is to make programming
fun and yeah thank you all for watching
Thank You Lawrence for for your
encouragement thank you all for joining
and I'll see you in the next live stream
have a great great day forward bye